is mel's maybe I shouldn't be wearing
this jacket well you'll notice that I've
switched to my summer jacket yes but
that's very nice guy flying to summer
jacket actually need to get another one
then a little worn but I I wear it as a
trophy of my six hours spent on the
assassins crew team I see Assassin's
Creed a team but is the crew I mean
never would be enough and that's it's
going to be a great shirt actually
anyway in honor of summer we are
drinking Aloha series cocoa brown from
Kona brewery which is a beer with
flavored coconut yeah I have a toasted
coke Ivan if I thought about had my
first sip some years I've been drinking
this all week very very nice I that now
excellent yeah they don't think I was da
coconut you know okay so just just to
get this off I am wearing a bicycle
helmet today that is mostly to protect
myself and case my coworker decides to
club me over the head during this review
process but it's also an honor of
National Bike Week and I care a lot
about the environment I was outside
earlier today and I did actually bike to
work yesterday and might work too yeah
for bike to work day so it's great to be
out there I did not like to work today
though so that was really a case of do
as I say don't do as I do but you can
drive your Prius to work I did I did but
I actually didn't I got dropped off my
carpool to work this morning so no not
like you better yeah exactly so my eye
on the other end I'm still tooling
around in my 1995 acura integra but it's
an excellent it is absolutely an
excellent car so my own path I used to
drool over those back in nineteen
ninety-five so used to drool over a lot
in 1985 probably i was just drooling in
general at night alright so we have we
have a list of actual seven games we're
going to take a look at some more
in-depth than others and we're going to
start off with looking at super daddio
free and just because something says
it's got super in the name does not
actually mean that it's super well i
think that once you show the game yes um
all right here we are
so this is I mean this is really fun if
this is this is this is retro gaming
kind of retro retro when you when you're
more retro than the original game then I
think that you've out retro you know
Super Mario Brothers this is kind of it
you know I and well and then that was
really my objection of this title right
is it it is a super mario brothers
ripoff I already did homage Oh mob
so Maj ripoff is such a strong word it's
better spit it's the question really is
kind of when I look at the game is it
two things one is it cool to have
something that's really low res like
this and is it is it or would have been
more cool how they actually updated the
graphics and is it actually fun and is
it at least as fun as the original or
more right and the answer in this case
is no I know I'd love to say I'd love to
say it was now there are some nice
things they've done one thing you notice
is I can actually tap on the screen I
don't actually have to use the virtual
buttons that makes said the virtual
buttons don't actually respond to any
way to let the user know that they think
they're being pressed which would be
really really nice but at least from you
conceive that possession I can control
daddio here but by this and I can you
know I can make him jump and it's not
exactly the original same as the
original game there's actually some new
game elements you can actually grab
these blocks over here I throat and you
can actually use this and that's
actually protects you also as you're
running so there's these little
creatures generated zombies come out I
don't think so but that's kind of that's
I was kind of cool to see a different
game so you know as I said I would call
it in a homage and it's you know it's
it's again it's obviously kind of a fun
it looks like a fun hobby project and
cool i like to see fun hobby projects on
hundred on google play you know it's
getting a little bit of extra gameplay
absolutely yeah so let's talk about what
separates this from what we call a retro
game okay so if you look at the graphics
there's pieces of this are are
definitely definitely feel like they
were originally written for a 16-bit
platform but remember that you know
16-bit programmers and artists were
actually pretty good they did a lot with
what they had
if you look back here in the background
you know you see this kind of monochrome
things you know look like they were done
in and maybe like paint brush or
something I it's it's a far cry from the
sort of things that you saw in you know
being made and deluxe paint for instance
where every pixel really counted and
there was a lot of care put into you
each piece of the background yeah so you
know this is just a solid green this is
you know a little bit textured but not
much just two colors in a van 60 cause
you work but he used as much as they
possibly could oh yeah ever get amounts
of dithering error diffusion just a all
done by hand of course and it was
beautiful it was beautiful painstaking
work and it required you know artists
with kind of special skill you know
nearly um so you know I mean I and I
think that's that that's exactly hit you
hit your head on the nose there also
just the fact that you know the graphics
are different kind of retro resolutions
all over you've got a really retro
looking tree the mountains are actually
higher resolution and the whole thing
feels fun but it doesn't it is it does
it just feels like you know I didn't
have time to actually write real
graphics so for my little for my project
I've gone and done this now that being
said the parallax scrolling is great
there's you know the game engine seems
fine you know it's just it's simply a
question of artwork and you know and and
up also it you know in terms of in
tuning the game and making a game
actually you know really fun and I think
that's you know that's that's a harder
thing for me to say about talked about
you know whether the game was fun if
this game looked like this and it just
played amazingly and it felt really good
in the physics felt really great as
you're running and all that I probably I
would have been more excited about it
but as it is it's just it's kind of fun
to look at it works well on I'll tell
you what would happen if this game
played amazingly well like it was just a
really really fun game to play and it's
not terribly i mean it just needs polish
right yes if it did play that well you
know what would happen is you would
almost certainly find a set of artists
that are willing to help you out and I'm
sort of time yeah i mean this this car
is sort of this game is sort of like
Ian's car you know it you know except
that Ian's car was actually awesome in
1995 well while while this game wouldn't
have been awesome
right so what you're saying is it's it's
more like a nineteen ninety-five toyota
prius i actually like yeah i like it
like if you tried it like you took a
toyota prius and tried to make it like
it was made in 1995 I don't know circuit
anyways tell you that does that don't
that analogy doesn't work at all let's
go to the next game so the next game on
this list is uh actually i'm gonna guess
which one would be anything you want in
particular we did no no no well so i
think we should talk about a few of the
ones so like cash or card katra crash or
crash so um i looked at this game and
honestly I couldn't really bring myself
to play it very much I kind of never
really figured the game play out it's
very very as far as I can tell it's kind
of pretty simple you basically have a
studt you can see you actually have in
the middle of a game here it does lie at
least sit nicely save your game state as
far as i can tell you i have ten dollars
and i can do something like by one
potato here at these different prices
and then eventually the price will go up
hopefully oh i just lost everything
because the price went down to zero so
the key thing is to sort of will follow
the trends of the market to buy and sell
and I looked at it was like this is just
not very interesting or compelling but
it could be it could be it yeah you know
we have seen a lot of games that we
thought were terrible and it turns out
that a lot of it is just in the fine
tuning and in the presentation so for
instance if you look right now one of
the top grossing games on Google Play is
basically a web game it just monetizes
really well because it engages people
with some very pretty artwork and a sort
of addictive style of game play now
whether or not you can turn this into
the addictive style of gameplay that
would make it top grossing is sort of up
in the air
think we've really played it enough so I
think it definitely does need some
tweaking yeah but the main thing it
needs is better presentation especially
presentation that sucks people in so
they want to keep playing even when they
don't know how yet and then teaches them
how to play so they can feel like
they've progressed yeah I kind of looked
at it and I didn't completely understand
what all would with these four columns
or four it looks like I by a different
tiers and the goal is to get myself up
to these higher tiers where I can make
more and more money off of different
Lots but there's also the ability to buy
ten of one lot so it was unclear why you
would just buy tons of this first column
maybe there's less risk in the third
columns there just wasn't it wasn't
really clear to me why the game was set
up this way and it's yeah so that's go
ahead and move on because the we do have
a lot to get through mm-hmm I think that
in general this this game just needs to
be a lot more self-explanatory and a lot
more polished yeah you know it and it is
it is a simple game but but you know
certainly simply people like it so I
mean I think it was worth continuing on
but you know in terms of whether you
know if the editorial board looked at
this they would be like uh well yeah
they they would actually come and kick
our butts first yeah I we both have
remarried I both have to wearing helmets
and it's not you know again elements
will not protect you no not at all oh
all right give us just one second though
for for a quick technical break so we do
have a guest online named birra and I I
think we've been unable to discover
which app he belongs to I rate to have
you had any oh hello Greg is that how
you say your name yeah how do you say
your name betta be dead okay eat it see
this is this is exactly how far away
that our monitor is for my sites ice
yeah that was an R which game did you
write time to rock and tiny little
racing time to rock Oh excellent
excellent why
we go ahead and switch over to that sure
so what can you tell us about this game
well it was developed in around a year a
year and in three months mm-hmm it's
based on a project I have for a 3d game
engine that I am take that I'm
developing for more than two years
already and it basically it gave me a
lot of work I worked a lot on it I
created everything from models to image
stone to text textures and I'm aware
that the thing that I must really fix
right now is the sound and music okay
that's basically I think well I gotta
tell you I you know we we actually saw
tiny little racing a couple months ago
because one of the guys that works on
the merchandising team picking with Japs
gets featured actually mention it to us
because he loves your game so nice
that's great yeah so there's a plus yeah
it's good to have that kind of support
so we might give you some more
constructive feedback today just because
we know you're already kind of gotten
Hannah yeah so now you know you said you
used your own game engine for this yeah
yeah oh and I built it from scratch I've
been developing it for more than four
years maybe it was a java ancient and
then i ported it to mobile okay that's
really cool awesome and now is that just
you or you have a team no it's just me
right now I still have to make some
money to pay more people to help me
raise I don't know make some partners
all right awesome well it said let's
check this out so you know how are you
so so let's let's help us walk through
the game here you know we're
we're at the main menu what would you
suggest we do to start off to show off
the game the most oh I don't know it'll
walk to da options I think I need to
know my career and free raise all right
into a free race that's how we want
ultra level of detail yeah yeah we're on
ultra level of detail and we wanted a
control type right that you mentioned
for us all right hop together with the
buttons together because they it will be
easier to turn buttons together yes okay
yeah that does help a lot um I would
actually say one thing is would be
really really great is if you see that
you're running on an extra large screen
device like a tablet it'd be kind of
awesome too yeah just to set up this
config that was actually one of my first
comments was that was that having the
having this config be you know sort of
automatic so allowing in a change is
great because not everyone is going to
agree on the same control scheme but
it's so easy to detect it it's an extra
large display and and you know it's a
great idea yeah so it'd be cool to do
and it's actually I mean the way I would
probably do it is I would just create a
environment variable that got triggered
if you detect it either large or
extra-large or in terms of Android now
we're looking at the minimum screen
width of 600 the SW 600 variable you can
trigger that off of actually something
in the resource fork so it's pretty it's
really really easy to do to just use the
resources to do that alright difficulty
know i love i love the word resource for
I think it's been 10 or 15 years I know
I know you can tell that I'm an all new
mac at all but I think resource actually
I guessed when I saw the beard but yeah
I said babe mm-hmm all right so let's go
ahead and get out of the options and try
a little Free raise absolutely by the
way difficulty is 2 f's um so yeah just
let me know you know that's that's such
a common thing actually especially with
individual developers if you can get
somebody to just proof read all your
text especially if you're localizing to
another language I get really help so
here we are says a race that you like
the bags have to go this one time in
Lafayette all right you know I talk all
right here we are classy normal
let's see this is cool you got the the
rotating car view and it was very
professional absolutely yeah I mean in
general I mean obviously you know what
this game would be really helped by
getting my king some artists on it I
mean you got you did an amazing job for
one guy I mean it's just so actually
there's a lot of things I in fact I
think there's really only one thing
that's going to drive art is crazy and
that's the fact that you use Comic Sans
as a fine yeah that's I I don't know
that's the only thing it'll drive
artists crazy time I'm always impressed
by what will drive art is crazy in what
won't i will say by the way that the
control scheme here when you have both
the arrows next to each other on a
tablet is just so much more awesome but
the physics feel great and the game is
really fun and I actually what I really
like about the game is that is the way
you can actually bounce off the walls so
you actually go through a kind of a
crazy turn you can actually you can't
actually bounce off the walls and it's
not in this particular in this
particular level it's actually doesn't
it doesn't immediately kill you can
actually kind of take advantage of that
the other point is also which is cool
it's it's very Arcadian a lot of you
know it's totally and there's also you
think there's also mind you can throw it
at people you know I definitely you know
on the fun factor of this game you
really the only thing that in my mind it
that prevents this game from from going
on and being like one of the top titles
is is go is in terms of you know getting
getting the art just up to the level of
the standard that's out there because
it's you know it's it's honestly
honestly the game is really good the
sound the sound is is good the models of
the cars are actually quite good
especially when you see them at scale in
the game oh we just want to take some
eyes okay we'll go grab that but but
what I really want to see is kind of the
the neck kind of the next level
especially when terms that comes to the
background textures and stuff like that
especially since there's so much there's
so many good freely available when it
comes to background textures that's the
easiest thing to go and get you know in
terms of in terms of being able to go
out and purchase really inexpensive
content yeah it's true although it feels
like you can always tell you can but
usually that yes I you know again it's
one of those things where it's mixed
because when you mix art styles and you
get
I obvious but you're already mixing our
tiles here in terms of the teton away
the textures in the car later yeah and
and certainly the the textures so what's
the conceit here is this a is this like
radio controlled model cars or is it
supposed to be full-size cars yeah I
think it's more like a mix of them I've
I I must admit that I I wasn't able to
decide if I were going with remote
controlled models or full-size models so
it's kind of both actually they're kind
of cartoony little cars which is fine
there you know and the track definitely
feels like I mean you never see a real
world track at scale that way but it
does look like the kind of thing that
you might find you know in a I would
have seemed very expensive remote
control facility yeah I want I want to
take away this remark in coach r ya car
track I'd be all right because it looks
like cobblestones yeah a little bit
totally um so yeah I don't I got have as
big of a problem with the with the
background what's most like that it's
mostly not the bottoms he's mostly the
mountains though the rocks around it any
kind of the restive backdrop the ground
is is different looks distinctly
different than the cars but you know i'd
love to see i'd love to see a little
more detail in the stuff around the
other thing that's going to make a big
difference in a racing game like this is
is some actual contact shadows under the
wheels you're doing in shadows but just
yeah get the ambient included on the
road around the wheels and then you'll
really be able to tell how far off the
ground it is yeah aside from what you
can see there there are also like
another five different environments
which each cup has a different
environment so there are more
environments on as long as you play on
the carrier mode and you every career
you you play you unlock another level
another car so you can vary your player
a little own future cars there are nice
tools also and do a different type of
mind so I try
two very little to gameplay as a player
is progressing through the game it
sounds like a lot of but you know what
has reminds me of racing destruction
said totally that no I haven't it I'm
probably a lot younger than I came out
in 1986 yeah something like that yeah it
was in the mid eighties yeah it was very
similar where you got it you know these
little tiny cars yeah actually they had
a track construction it was the band the
cars and it was racing destruction set
that was the mid 80s right there we all
about you and Gary Newman's yeah all
right yeah it was all been sparse back
then even though the hardest sucked
that's right about that it's true yeah
so um I guess I was talking I just had
since we have you as a developer can you
talk I want to ask you a couple
questions when you went to test this and
bring this to to Google Play what
devices did you have to test it on well
I I have five devices i have a tu duc
fun android device a phablet up i don't
know i don't remember do you know a lot
of your tablet nice annaclaire tablet
actually that's a first oh yeah you're
right yeah that's not expensive I know I
doubt that's a yeah we never actually
made any of those in turn right we don't
actually call them tablets we call them
big phones yeah and from their twitter
and what else did yet i have five more
the scanner can i say the name of mono
surgery yeah um Shaikh x10 galaxy x 2mm
and and I GALEX top 10 inches those are
the base models that I that I test on
because they have different OS versions
well they also voted hose yeah they also
different GPU which is nice to you are
actually you're actually getting a nice
brea the xperia has a has a qualcomm
adreno base GPU the s2 of course is the
arm mali most likely the
it was it was the other one that was
their theme so he had this yeah the sony
a7 and then he said I the clare tablet
yeah and there was one ellisa 5 right
after he didn't mention spy I don't know
where to know it's uh archos I think oh
yeah yeah yeah those most of those i
think i can't remember they used of
these a variety of chips a little bunch
them we roam at base or wouldn't
surprise me if it was PVR i think it so
that's a no math three device I think
but that's just plain awesome we don't
actually know like which one which is
the galaxy s T's had Molly's almost all
of them except for I think there's like
there's like a couple in the u.s. mostly
in a couple in Russia but I don't know
about down unaware you located I'm
located in Brazil in Brazil that's what
I thought I'm not sure about the
Brazilian I think the Brazilian models
were all on Molly as well but I am you
know it's a weird we're in Brazil are
you i am include chiba Oh crece la south
uh-huh awesome awesome well we've got to
continue on to the to the rest of the
games but thanks so much for coming on
and as there any is there any kind of
wisdom you want to impart to drill two
other developers kind of you know to
think something they got you got stuck
on that you know that you'd say hey this
was something I would definitely do or
not do well ma I think one of my biggest
problems is memory management because
when you are working with 3d and trying
to make the quality of the textures look
us as bad as better as the best as
possible you try to use a lot of memory
and since you have that many devices and
you're trying to be as much back
backward compatible as you can I think
memory management in knowing how to load
the textures and in which resolution to
load the pressure is very important
absolutely for games did you did you add
you experiments at all with using
texture compression ah I need to check
that I I think in my testers are a
compressive we're not sure I usually
open shell too yeah the one because
because basically most most of
if you're using textures that don't have
alpha it looks like a bunch of your
stone most of devices will support ET c
1 texture compression and that allows
that actually allows you to reduce the
amount of memory in video memory that
the texture is going to take but if I
recall the samsung galaxy s2 doesn't
support them no it does it does it does
yeah it supports gonna check on that
yeah so that might be something to look
at to help to help you to optimize
memory a little bit and also will give
you a little boost in fill rate because
it also reduces since it decompresses as
it fills it actually it actually it
reduces the size of the copy of the
texture so it it actually gives you a
little boost in fill rate too so it's
worth looking into especially if you
have a bunch of textures that don't have
alpha built into them so what was I
thinking oo is it's that it doesn't
support anything but ET c 1 right right
so there are other other formats to like
the XTC that are that are supported in
PB ortc at are supported individual
chips but you know if you have a texture
that looks good in etc1 and pretty much
anything that doesn't have radical
changes in color like if it has text
built into the texture etc1 will
compress it very well but if it's like
your background texture for the ground
that looks to me like it would compress
with very very little loss in quality in
dtc one that's why i said--that's why i
was suggesting that anyways it's great
talking to you it's awesome to see what
you've done it's an amazing project for
a single person project my hat would go
off to you except that it's it's chained
in my head with this strap so uh let's
move on to the next game thanks a lot
for coming i'll make it thank you so
next game i want to look at is this is a
game called mac hunter and this actually
also comes from brazil from deon game
studios and we looked at another day on
title a couple weeks ago was asteroid
defense okay absolutely something so i
Mac which I found to be utterly
addictive yeah then makes great game so
this game it uses accelerometer for play
and it looks just great on tablets you
can see here that it's it's just it's
just awesome looking like the graphics
are really high resolution I you know
those of you are watching this an HD
you'll really get to see kind of you
what this is looking like and you know
the interface is very intuitive and
again you know it's getting 60 frames
per second here on my transformer prime
now but you'll notice that as I turn the
tablet to try to try to make him swing
it actually doesn't work and the reason
why is that this tablet is a landscape
default device and the way the
accelerometer and Android works is it
actually gives you coordinates that are
that are based upon the default
orientation of the device so as a game
developer what you actually need to do
is translate and there's actually
functions that are built into the SDK to
help you out with this but this may
shock you there i'm actually going to
refer you to the nvidia website because
they actually have the best article on
how to take these accelerometer
coordinates which are either going to be
based on portrait or landscape depending
on the default orientation and turn them
into a general solution that will work
across all devices without you having to
care about the orientation it turns out
that it's simpler the most people thing
and in fact where most people go wrong
is trying to find out too much of it
about the device and trying to be too
clever yes so what I'm doing is I'm
actually playing this with the tablet in
the wrong orientation and the reason by
the way I know this isn't the correct
orientation of the game as I also did
tried this on my phone and the phone it
actually worked in a much more intuitive
way so this is actually one of the few
things it doesn't really matter whether
it's a phone or a tablet it matters what
the default orientation is most phones
are default portrait most tablets are
default landscape but that's not
necessarily true so you can find some of
you know for instance some of the
sliding keyboard phone yeah our default
landscape so so that being said the game
is really fun it's it's it's quite I
really like the accelerometer control
and as you can see the graphic style is
really really high res and sharp and it
looks great against this background I
mean this is yet another another another
you know i would say hit from the guys
over at e.on this is a no great effort
here and certainly something we'd like
to look at the only other thing I would
I wanted to comment on was when i
completed the level the back he actually
doesn't work and while during the game
and during the rest of the game the back
he does something every
we're here all of a sudden I hit back
and nothing happens and you know
obviously it since since going to the
next level automatic wouldn't make sense
hitting in here really should just take
me back to the menu and and without that
the navigation would feel would be
basically right as I said an arrest the
game it does work normally they hit back
here on the HOME key it actually takes
me back out to the to the desktop so you
know it's been done well but the thing
is is that we really want to make sure
that whenever the user presses that key
it does something something that makes
sense you know so not something like
exit the youth exit the game without
telling user anything work but something
like taking user back in the stack so
it's something to definitely have you
know QA team go through the game look at
this is something that our QA when
they're when they're looking at final
featuring ciple so when it's gone
through everything and they're just
checking to make sure things are all
working right because we always want to
make sure things are looking really good
before the team features them they're
going to look at they're going to find
this I'm going to say hey developer you
need to fix this so that's just an early
heads up go through your titles make
sure that in every single part of the
game make sure the back heat does
something well even if it works in
ninety percent of the cases if there's
that one percent where it doesn't work
that that's a huge deal so basically the
two things to focus on here definitely
in my you know that I noticed our Excel
our accelerometer and and the back key
and we should also go through these
little icons here at the bottom which I
always which I strongly recommend and so
we got blender by the way I love people
who use blender I'm a huge blunder fan
so props there guys we have we actually
have have the facebook page here you
know real basic stuff you know as always
we recommend that you use the Android
share intent and we'll hit facebook i'll
hit Twitter it'll hit google+ but
whatever you know next year brings in
terms of hot social networks it will hit
that too so you really want to use the
share intent so you don't miss out and
this is really nice actually this does
this feedback that in fact that it just
popped me up into anything they'll take
accidentally you know it probably better
do saying is slightly more time tune
towards mail I think you buy it yeah if
i typed in the docs my feedback not sure
what would happen actually but that case
overall you know i said i say thumbs up
as i said the accelerometer is the
biggest thing that's the most important
thing secondly maybe navigation and the
third thing would be make sure to use
our standard share if you want to make a
custom share for something else you know
that's cool but at least make sure our
standard sharing is there because then
you end up supporting any social network
any mechanism from text to email that
happens to support those those intense
and I'd love to see you know with the
game like this would be cool to do stuff
like screenshots and stuff like that the
game is just so fun and goofy and I just
love what you guys who dumped the art
style so absolutely well you know the
art style I just want to make one
comment yes it seemed really nice that
the art itself is really nice but when
do you think about the animations on
thur a little wooden a little bit a
little bit I mean I was overall happy I
thought it but they were there I thought
they were kind of over the top in a cool
way um it's a sort of intentional yeah
I'm a lot of times we talk about you
know it's stuff that took an hour to do
an illustrator and obviously this isn't
yeah I think I think I think a lot of it
I think a lot of it had to do you have
to do we have to moving parts right yeah
and and yeah at at which I would love to
see more animation beyond the tail yeah
you know it'd be cool to have it you
know heavy legs and arms swinging around
as well you know said I love the art I
agree with the end the animation could
definitely be there it'd be cool to have
some different segments on him
especially since you know the fluid and
also you know it'd be cool to have the
vines doing kind of more natural
swinging too if you're going to actually
do vines these look like poles right at
it yeah it looks very very stuff and
here's the thing it's this isn't just
about polish or you know our personal
feelings about animations we see that
games with recognizable characters tend
to do better if the user can sympathize
with them yeah so you can't sympathize
with something that looks like a static
picture with a piece of rope tie it on
his ass yeah
no actually what I would even go farther
to say that you know what squids would
be really cool so but if he's hanging
like this I'd love to see him do an
animation saying hey do you not I'm
impatient i want to swing never and x
there's so much work that's been done in
these backgrounds having that character
who's already an awesome looking
character be just that much more
animated and right make him feel like
he's a lot so you i think what i would
think that that would be the way to take
this to the next next level i told you i
agree you know 100 comment there I that
that's that's really important point so
the other the only other thing I would
say is when we go I'll show you one
other little thing here which is a minor
pet Pete but I might as well just talk
about it since I really like this game
so I go to the home screen and I go back
into into matt hunter and so I'm here
and I says okay now the problem is is
that i don't know where I came from here
so I didn't bring up this dialog so the
fact that I'm saying that it says okay
is kind of confusing I would much rather
ahead it's a resume I would much rather
you know to let me know that I'm going
back in the game and immediately
swinging that would be the only other
nitpicky current I have you know in
terms of that but otherwise you know
great what's also about putting up that
kind of dialogue when you go when the
game is back rounded is not only to
pause things and keep things out of the
way but it also guarantees that you
won't ever play music on the lock screen
exactly just kind of avoids the whole
problem so for a game that's got
real-time action like this you know you
know it's really popping that up is
great but again the fact that it says
okay is kind of wacky so i would
definitely i would definitely have it
say presume that's Bridgette time for
the lightning round time for the
lightning round all right so no next
three games and 30 seconds two lists
okay that's good let's go to draw on
guess so drawn guess is one of these
games that is actually a pretty cool
idea it takes a lot of you a lot of the
mechanic shops then I draw something and
it makes it into this social room game
we have a whole bunch of people who are
trying to figure out what someone is
drawing fastest and so here and I'm
hoping this isn't going to be something
objectionable times or the waters us
whether were the words I lead people to
draw things that are more objection
others and so we're kind of a you know
with a live production that looks to me
like a cigarette what do you think yeah
I'd go for cigarette their cigarette or
a french fries dipped in mustard and
ketchup it could be cigarette nope
doesn't look like a cigarette everyone
thinks think it seems to agree with me I
hope this is something phallic all right
so um it's a pub a cigar okay we do have
some sort of issue with the oh yeah yeah
they're yeah you should probably keep
this on the table and yeah Hector isn't
super study yeah sorry about that guys
for at least an all right so when people
try to drop stuff ziga Ziggy oh it's a
ziggy c de rigueur rocked ziggurat oh my
god so z oh no I just wanted i do want
to let our audience know that I'd sighs
cigarettes and cigarette Carlotta
actually the frame things that's Rob see
people playing all over the world here
so there's a lot of things actually in
this game that are pretty cool now you
know what I should do is say the drawer
the drawer are used text you know and to
the game encourage you to write down
someone who just draws with text but you
know this person actually also tried to
draw it but it's one of those things
where you know you know that's what the
game encourages is just be sort of so
maybe they tried to do the Shred singh-
c plus c yeah they did they did my guess
is they don't actually know what a
cigarette is I'm sure they don't I yes
I'm not so I'm not exactly common
knowledge so um we know of course
because we went to college no because
we're Google we know everything right
welcome i know i would see to things you
can always check you can always google
it next door I'm finite you sear on it
was supposed to tell people about the
brain implants oh sorry sorry I Project
X so I'm jinx so actually the main menu
here looks pretty good on tablets the
game itself definitely could use some
upgrades for tablets one of the things
that's kind of confusing when you're
developing a game or any application
using the standard android framework for
a tablet is these devices show up as
being an mdpi device and that means that
the default behavior is to allow the
user to see a lot more information on
the screen and it also
accurately represents the density the
pixel density of the device the problem
is is it what that means in this case is
it the icons are really really small you
can see on that on that left and right
side they're almost unprecedented for
small so this is where it really makes
sense to actually have resources that
are dynamically size based upon the
screen size rather than just based upon
the density because this you know this
is just a layout that extent expanded
out very very large from a phone version
that being said I've certainly seen a
lot worse yeah some guys like go draw
something please so okay let's take that
off so um so hot in case as I said the
one problem you have with this sort of
this sort of title is you do have
user-generated content it's the
chatroulette of draw some it is it is
absolutely the good news is the drawing
tools aren't very high-rez so I'd like
to see um I'd like to see it really get
a you know some more tablet love but
I'll but overall a creative game a fun
game one thing that it does do you know
which is you know things to note about
it is like force focus on tap let's go
to the next ones we've got more to do
here yeah this is a lightning round it
is a lightning round I know so let's go
to X late now actually made me really
really sad because it's actually not
officially available on the transformer
prime here it is actually officially
eliminated from google play market place
but it plays just fine and I tried it on
two different devices just to compare
and there was no reason why it shouldn't
be on this device so guys eliminate that
put it on the device one thing you'll
notice on tablets is that if you have a
dialogue that's full screen on a tablet
like this it looks kind of ridiculous
I'm bill is harder it's hard to see it
on the screen here but this is like an
absolute first first glance of why it
makes sense on a tablet if you have a
dialogue with just three things like
this to actually turn it into a dialogue
you know just having it you know it's a
it's you know they'll make sure it never
gets incredibly large like this but that
being said it's certainly workable
no one's going to say don't feature it
because it has a giant dialogue like
that but it'd be nice in the game itself
what I really really wanted was actually
the game more fun and I think I
understand what's going on is that I
think that if i upgrade my weapons to to
to an exceptional point the game is
going to get more fun so this is
actually kind of cool this is actually
we're in this position of not fighting
you can actually talk to people this is
sort of a it actually has a really
really cool story like story built into
it there's a planet you actually it's a
little confusing the first time you play
the game that you realize you actually
have to go button and this takes you to
a dialogue which then allows you to
select a planet to fly to I would just
say you know for this dialogue it would
be nice to see that skinned yeah it's a
little skinned already but it'd be nice
it'd be nice to see it kind of more skin
oh you're right the angle on its not to
you so you're right it is a little skin
but still there's there's a lot of the
just standard system dialogue well the
other thing is there's there's really no
reason to me like it right why it really
needs to be a dialogue like I really
want to I really want to have like Venus
Mars blah these desks appear and be
available at the top of the screen or
something like that I think I think I
think it'd be a lot easier to understand
the control scheme is pretty good it's
kind of the classic control scheme for
these kind of shooter games the frame
rate could be a little bit higher and I
don't really you know I don't have
advice on how I'm how to fix that for
this particular titles I don't know
really know how it was constructed
whether this was just designed to run at
this frame rate or not this is the right
great ran on both the Galaxy Nexus and
on this device um the main problem i
have with it is that is it the levels
are actually quite long and grinding and
i can see you know the goal is to make
it so you grind through these things
that takes a really really long time to
grind through them so you can finally
get your weapons so you could actually
get to the next level but my problem
with it was it wasn't it was just not
very fun with this gun that fires kind
of slowly and singly and you know it
takes a lot of time to take things out
you're the awesome power of so i can
ganda well they're all things there's
nothing you can pick up you can't do
this which is an overload language which
gives you the techni bility
temporarily improve your firepower and
which is kind of cool you see it's
running down now and then you'll end up
back with a single shot but you know
which helps a lot but there's definitely
you know a feeling love like wow it's
gonna take me forever to get to the
point where my weapons are fun enough or
I'm going to buy something and so you
know i think there's got to be a balance
my feeling was it wasn't quite
compelling enough to start off with i
kind of wanted a little bit more fun
maybe the weapons be a little bit weaker
but fire a little faster or something
like that i would play with the balance
there or maybe just give me give me an
extra weapon to whet my appetite wow
that i can kind of see why i would want
to buy something did you blew my ship
off my lap I lost 792 credits um sorry
man that's all right uh risk you take
this I can't help you through the bike
helmet yeah I'm other way so here's
here's here's an example of something
that actually you've got to be very
careful with so um you know we always
say make sure the back he does something
so this developer when the backe hits it
pops up this dialog except there's no
way to leave still like you know so this
so this this would not pass the process
because they'd say well there's no way
to exit back should at least lead me to
something if it doesn't actually allow
me to exit it should lead me to
something that suggests that I can exit
yeah we're fine with popping up and
interstitial so that you don't
accidentally leave an action scene
without being able to get right back
into the game but the intent of the back
button is not just to pop up a menu the
intent of the back button is to let you
go back yeah and it would be it's you
know it's so that's that's that's a good
example there of what not to do next
game we're going to look at is a word
drop it's our final game of the
afternoon and we're drop is actually
really really fun but although I'll go
through a couple of things I noticed
when I was looking at it one is that it
actually integrates score loop and
that's not that much that's much not not
too much of a problem I'm except that I
kept ending up crashing when I kept a
when I loaded up the score loop
dialogues it may be that it that they
don't like ice cream sandwich there
might be some other
I didn't have time to actually
investigate what was going on but you
know got to be careful if you're
integrating a third-party library all we
got to make sure to be checking these
things out you know yeah for me it just
was a it was an instant crash on all of
that and then remember you know we have
we've actually gotten a lot of questions
about this and we've asked the policy
team we've got some merchandising team
and everyone's feeling is you know
people will say hey my game is great
it's just this middleware that that is
growing up well the truth is you know to
put that middleware in there yeah you
are responsible for all the aspects of
your title so if you violate policy or
you know come fall short of our hour
featuring guidelines in any way even if
it's not your fault personally it
reflects on your yeah you know this is
middleware you've chosen to put in
whether it's you know an ad company with
it was running ads that violate our
guidelines or a or a in this case it's a
part of it that crashes or forces you to
put a vest digital menu button now one
thing that's cool about this is you
notice there is no vestige with manual
button here down at the bottom of the
screen which is great no buttons of
shame levels of shame and the moment of
the game are fun i they're pretty close
and what's cool is you can actually
resume individually between panic puzzle
time and puzzle extreme cool so that's
it actually it actually is pretty cool
that way I would actually like to see
some indication that i have a game in
process there on the main screen and as
you see I've been playing this game a
lot so so what's the jimbo so basically
your goal is to make words so you know I
can so I can make different words I know
dance and you know something like that
and you are huge on word games are you
that I that is your passion is I think I
think I know I wouldn't say it's a
passion but I really really like them
and I'm going to die here pretty pretty
quickly in this but I can do actually
save and quit so I can go back and
continue playing that later so overall I
really like it and I actually thought it
was a really really cool game you can um
I wanted a little bit more there's a
have a general
rank with you in the rest of the world
but I think it'd be kind of cool to even
make it a little more competitive I'd
love to see like a head-to-head
competition mode where you both were
trying to make words out of the same
letter drops at the same time you kind
of watch what was going on like this is
it be fun I mean I'd look I just love to
see it go to the next level it's a good
game it's a well done game it runs well
here the one thing that it does do when
you quit it does it pops you up in
interstitial when you exit and I would
say dude I'm trying to exit the app it's
one thing to do it after I play but
after actually exiting and I'll show you
it's a police force by completing free
offers at least it doesn't pop you
straight there into it which would be
really obnoxious but generally they you
know the concept of I'm trying to exit
with the back key so I'm actually
closing you and also offer well
sometimes ask you to rape the game and
it is cool you know it you know it lets
you know that you know if you probably
problems you know but as my general
feeling is the back putting those up on
the on back is really not the place to
put them partially because the user can
always take hit home and get straight to
home you know there's you know so it's
really just a question of how they're
exiting in general when they hit back
you know unless you're in the middle of
a game it should just take you back and
one I don't know I don't know if I
because you like you said they the user
can always hit home but I'll tell you
this is a this is exactly what xbox live
arcade Dan all of its trial mode yeah I
you know I I think I think you haven't
decided yeah personally I think it's
intensely annoying and when I get
annoyed by something I'm less likely to
pay money for it I'm more likely to go
find something else yeah so it may be
counterproductive on the other hand if
it works for you hmm you say you know
you can always get out of it yeah i'm
yeah what know what our team what are
featuring committee would say about that
I don't know no as it does violate our
navigation to to actually to actually go
and and actually exit so just just just
remember people who didn't catch the
beginning of the broadcast I am wearing
the helmet because it is national by
week here in the United States and we
did a bike to work day yesterday I
actually did bike to work yesterday and
that's why I'm hardly walking today and
so I did not like to work today but
excited to put the helmet on just to
kind of show my support for for biking
and for alternative force forms of
transportation you know being a hippie
living up here and also thanked ammonia
yeah absolutely and I'm better than you
so big except I'm not because I'll tell
you i got i got creamed on the road by
the people actually bike on a regular
basis like I'd be there but I can't pump
it along some guy comes by you know
wearing the skin tight bicycle outfit so
um the other thing I the thing I note
about this game is that this particular
resolution the buttons on the home
screen actually all have a bit of an
error on on on the right hand side so
you can see there is this line that just
shows up yeah so it looks like there's
some minor offset their of either text
it's in the graphic or I don't know
imagine was Todd right along the side
one that is I guess it's hard to see but
um probably when you're online unless
you're watching this in high definition
but so but really a very very promising
game I let it's a nice spin on the
Wardrobe I said what I'd love this you
got what i want to see his word drop
plus plus is like all sorts of cool
multiplayer stuff i think that's kind of
what it's missing and it you know i i'd
love to see like random competitive
multiplayer ghosts multiplayer all that
kind of stuff would be really really
cool i think would take you to the next
level but congratulations guys well done
yep well thanks all for joining us
remember we do this every week and if we
find games that we like we nominate them
into the google play featuring process
now we don't have control over whether
they get accepted or not but what you
will find is that once we nominate you
you'll get some interesting feedback
from the google play featuring team and
the editorial board and that will often
help your game be better though and
we'll be sending out some more feedback
for several of the developers that we
looked at today if you'd like to have
your game appear on this show just go to
our moderator we post the link every
week there is on the left hand side a
category called Friday games review
and if you if you suggest your app in
there and people like it and they vote
for it then there's a really good chance
that we'll take a look at it and if your
regular watcher of this show I
definitely recommend looking at some of
the blog posts we've done on what gain
developers should know because a lot of
the stuff we go through in the Friday
review comes right off of those two blog
posts hopefully we'll do more in the
future talking about the kinds of things
really the the featuring committee looks
at as they're trying to make sure that
all of the applications and games that
are featured on Google Play really have
the same kind of quality bar really
navigate in a way that feels like
they're as native as possible and you
know and ultimately that's really the
goal here is that if you're playing a
game on android it just feels like the
game was meant for your device and
whenever you kind of get into the
position of huh this just doesn't feel
right it probably isn't and so I
definitely recommend reading through
those and making sure that when you
submit something to our Friday review
process that you've gone through it so
that we're not finding the same things I
love being able to dig a little deeper
and find cooler and better stuff to talk
about and there's a lot of fun stuff
this week accelerometer is definitely
one of those things that is tricky if
you haven't done it before on Android
because it is again based on the default
orientation if you only have a phone
device you're probably not going to see
what happens with the landscape
orientation and unfortunately it's not
something we support directly in the
emulator so that's it I think that's it
for us for this friday yep have a grab a
great weekend and be well and have have
a great time playing games we will see
you next time same time same place nope
different play different place this is
the US actually are our final broadcast
we believe unless unless the group
doesn't go well movie but yeah but in
sometime in the next week or two we will
be broadcasting from the former office
of Andy Rubin yeah and Andy has has
generously donated his former office to
these broadcasts and I kind of I kind of
hope we could find some some his former
election about Indian
I'm not a roofie has donated his former
Scott like I think makes valued up two
or three thousand dollars for the five
bottles that were there you think that
little know it was I yeah but it was
it's really great show of support for
what we're doing here thanks for all of
you for watching out there and we're
going to try and make sure that the show
just gets better and better every week
please continue giving us feedback you
know letting us know what you think and
please keep nominating and please keep
writing great games and if you want to
appear on the program just let us know
we post the list night before and you
can down the program and talk with us
your feedback doesn't matter you'll
notice that last week we got a lot of
feedback about how the show is fairly
long and it was difficult to find what
you were looking for if you're just
looking for a single app we have place
captions throughout the the show so
hopefully that helps we look at every
piece of feedback we get so please let
us know what we can do better all right
thanks a lot guys have a great week and
we'll see you next time
you